أود أن أناقش آخر
جهودنا لمعالجة
الوضع الإنساني في غزة وتعزيز
السلام الدائم بشأن
الوضع الإنساني الفوري الذي بين أيدينا، إن
أولوياتنا ثلاثية
ومتشابكة بشكل أساسي أولاً، ونواصل رفع الأمر
إلى القيادة الإسرائيلية على أعلى المستويات.
مستويات الضرورة الأخلاقية والاستراتيجية
المتمثلة في بذل المزيد من الجهد لمنع
وقوع إصابات في صفوف المدنيين، ونحن نعلم أن حماس
تزرع نفسها بين المدنيين
والبنية التحتية المدنية وبالتالي
تعرض المدنيين للخطر، ومع ذلك فإن هذا لا يقلل من التزامات إسرائيل بموجب القانون الإنساني الدولي.
إن مسألة الأطفال
مرتفعة للغاية في المرتبة الثانية مع انتقال إسرائيل إلى
عمليات أقل كثافة مع
تخفيض القوات في الشمال، وقد اتفقنا
على إرسال بعثة تقييم حاسمة تابعة للأمم المتحدة
لتقييم ما يجب
القيام به للسماح للفلسطينيين النازحين
بالعودة إلى ديارهم هناك.
سوف نتأكد من
البنية التحتية الأمنية المحددة والتحديات الإنسانية
وما يجب القيام به للتغلب على
تلك
العقبات. تؤدي الأمم المتحدة
دورًا لا غنى عنه في تلبية
الاحتياجات الإنسانية الهائلة في غزة، ويحظى
المنسق الكبير الجديد للشؤون الإنسانية وإعادة الإعمار في غزة، سيج
كوج، بدعمنا الكامل.  ونتوقع
أنها ستحظى بالتعاون الكامل من
كل دولة في المنطقة، كما
قالت الوزيرة في إسرائيل.
يجب أن يتمكن المدنيون الفلسطينيون من العودة إلى ديارهم
بمجرد أن تسمح الظروف بذلك، ويجب ألا
يتم الضغط عليهم لمغادرة غزة،
وترفض الولايات المتحدة بشكل لا لبس فيه أي
مقترحات.  ومن خلال دعوتنا إلى
إعادة توطين الفلسطينيين خارج
غزة، فإننا نرفض أيضًا
التصريحات التحريضية غير المسؤولة التي أطلقها
بعض المسؤولين الإسرائيليين والتي تدعو إلى
إعادة توطين الفلسطينيين خارج
غزة، ونفهم من رئيس
الوزراء نتنياهو أن هذه ليست
سياسة الحكومة الإسرائيلية
الثالثة بالتزامن مع  من أجل التخفيف بشكل أفضل من
الأضرار التي لحقت بالمدنيين
وبعثة التقييم التابعة للأمم المتحدة في الشمال، نحن بحاجة
إلى زيادة مستويات
المساعدة الإنسانية التي تدخل غزة بالإضافة إلى
توزيعها الفعال في جميع أنحاء غزة.
يعاني الكثير من المدنيين الفلسطينيين من عدم كفاية الوصول إلى
الغذاء والماء والأدوية وغيرها من
الإمدادات الأساسية التي نحتاجها.  شهدنا
تقدمًا ملموسًا بما في ذلك من خلال فتح
معبر شالوم للسيارات بين إسرائيل
وغزة، لكن المستويات الحالية لا تزال
غير كافية، ولا تزال العوائق التي تحول دون
التوزيع الفعال مرتفعة للغاية،
ونحن نواصل إثارة مع إسرائيل ومصر
وشركائها في المنطقة وفي جميع أنحاء
العالم الحاجة إلى  بذل كل ما
في وسعه لتعزيز مثل هذا العمل الحاسم،
بما في ذلك تحسين إجراءات منع التعارض
لضمان
توصيل المساعدات بشكل آمن ومأمون، مع السعي إلى تعزيز
هذه الأولويات العاجلة، كما
نعمل بنشاط على تعزيز
الأساس لمستقبل سلمي من خلال
إنشاء دولة فلسطينية
جنبًا إلى جنب.  ولكي تجعل إسرائيل ذلك ممكنا،
يجب على إسرائيل أن تكون شريكا للقادة الفلسطينيين
الذين هم على استعداد لقيادة
شعبهم للعيش جنبا إلى جنب في سلام
وأمن مع إسرائيل، ويجب على إسرائيل أن
تتوقف عن اتخاذ الخطوات التي تقوض
قدرة الشعب الفلسطيني على حكم
نفسه بشكل فعال
عنف المستوطنين المتطرفين  وتنفذ
مع الإفلات من العقاب، وتوسيع الاستيطان، وعمليات الهدم
والإخلاء،
وحجب
مدفوعات إيرادات المقاصة، وهذه كلها إجراءات
لا تقدم رؤية للسلام.
كما تتحمل السلطة الفلسطينية
مسؤولية إصلاح وتحسين
حكمها بحيث تتمكن من
دعم الشعب الفلسطيني بشكل فعال
التطلعات المشروعة لتحقيق
الرخاء والكرامة والأمن
والحرية، نحن ندرك هذه العقبات
ولا يعتقد أحد أن السلام سيتحقق بين
عشية وضحاها ولكننا نعمل
كل يوم مع القادة في المنطقة لتعزيز
جهودنا لمساعدة غزة
على الاستقرار والتعافي لرسم
مسار سياسي للمضي قدمًا من أجل
الفلسطينيون والعمل على تحقيق
السلام والأمن والاستقرار على المدى الطويل